Let's go to Revelation 2. Open up
Revelation 2. You ready?
Yes.
Read verses 8 to 9.
Might be having cat issues as well.
>> That's okay. I have a cat, too.
Sorry. See By the [clears throat] way,
your cat is black and your cat is
distracting you right at an important
moment. You know that's demonic, right?
I want you to lay hands on the cat, cast
out the demon. No, I'm just kidding. Go
ahead. Revelation 2
Revelation 2:8 to 9. 1 2. Okay.
Um to the angel of the church in Smyrna
write, "These are the words of him who
is the first and the last,
who died and came to life again.
I know your afflictions and your
poverty, yet you are rich. I know about
the slander of those who say they are
Jews and are not, but are a synagogue of
Satan." Wait, wait, wait, wait. Jesus
said there are Jews, but they're not
really Jews and their places of worship
belong to Satan?
Yes.
Jesus the Jew?
Jesus the Jew said these Jews, they're
fake, they're not real Jews and their
synagogues belong to Satan, not to God.
Yes. Wow. Now, he said that in
Revelation 2:8 to 9, right? Yes. But now
go to Revelation 3. Open up Revelation 3
and read 7 to 9.
Revelation 3:7 to 9.
>> [clears throat]
>> Revelation 3:7 to 9. Okay. "To the angel
of the church in Philadelphia write,
>> Focus now, guys. Don't debate each other
in the comment section. Focus and learn.
"These are the words of him who is holy
and true, who holds the key of David.
What he opens, no one can shut and what
he shuts, no one can open.
I know your deeds. See, I have placed
before you an open door that no one can
shut.
I know that you have little strength.
You have kept my word and have not
denied
I will make those who are of synagogue
of Satan, who claim to be Jews, though
they are not, but are liars. Wait. So,
there's another group of Jews living
somewhere else and what do they have in
common? They're not really Jews. They're
fake Jews and their synagogues belong to
Satan, not to God.
Yes.
Are you kidding me?
Now, one more time, Jesus is speaking to
what angel of what church in verse 7?
To the angel of the church in
Philadelphia. Now, watch this church in
Philadelphia. Read slowly verse 9. What
Jesus is going to make these Jews, who
are not really Jews, cuz they do not
know Jesus and if you don't know Jesus,
you're not a real Jew,
cuz a Jew is one inwardly like Paul
said, remember? Mhm. What is he going to
make them do? Look, reread Revelation
3:9.
"I will make those who are of the
synagogue of Satan, who claim to be
Jews, though they are not, but are
liars. I will make them come and fall
down at your feet and acknowledge that I
have loved you." Did you catch that,
sister?
If the Jews are God's chosen people, why
is Jesus making these Jews bow at the
feet of the church as a sign that I,
Jesus, love my church, you Jews who
reject me?
Can you explain that to me?
>> [clears throat]
>> No.
Reread verse 9 again. Let it sink in by
the power of the Holy Spirit. Revelation
3:9. What will Jesus make these Jews,
who reject Jesus, so ethnically they're
Jews, but inwardly they're not and their
places of worship belong to Satan, what
will he make them do? Reread it again.
Revelation 3:9. Guys, pay attention.
"I will make those who are of the
synagogue of Satan, who claim to be
Jews, though they are not, but are
liars. I will make them come down fall
down at your feet and acknowledge that I
have loved you." Love who?
Loved the
Christians. The church, right? Mhm.
But you keep telling me or the
evangelists keep telling me Israel is
God's chosen people.
Jesus just said,
"You, my church, I love you. You're my
body. I'm going to make those Jews who
reject me and hate you, cuz they hate
me, I'm going to make them bow before
you, so they can know that I love you."
When's the last time you heard your
church teach you this?
Um
never.
Now, go to Matthew 23. There's a few
more chapters. Matthew 23:37 to 39.
I got to give you a thorough because
they're going to try to explain this
away and lie.
Matthew 23:37 to 39. Look what Jesus
says is a sign that he's done with
Jerusalem.
He's done with Jerusalem,
earthly and he's done with the temple.
Here's the sign. Matthew 23:37 to 39.
Okay.
"Jerusalem, Jerusalem,
you who killed the prophets and stoned
those sent to you. How often I have
longed to gather your children together
as a hen gathers her chicks under her
wings,
and you were not willing.
Look, your house is left to you
desolate.
For I tell you, you will not see me
again until you say, 'Blessed is he who
comes in the name of the Lord.'" Okay,
did you catch what he said? This is your
final chance. You will not see me again
after this week unless you repent and
say, "Blessed is he who comes in the
name of the Lord." But they never did
that. And what did he say he's going to
now going to do to their temple?
Your house, the temple, will be left
desolate. The sign that I'm done with
you, I'm going to destroy your house,
Jerusalem. That's why in the next
chapter, Matthew 24, it's all about the
sign when Christ will come to destroy
Jerusalem and the temple.
Did Did you catch what Jesus saying?
Yeah.
He just said the sign that it's over,
I'm done with you, that I'm taking away
the kingdom,
is that you will not
accept me. You will not turn to me. You
will not say, "Blessed is he who comes
in the name of the Lord." In fact,
you're going to hand me over to be
killed and then you'll never see me
again after this week
and then I'm going to destroy your
house, Jerusalem, the temple, and I'm
going to destroy Jerusalem as a sign
it's done between you and I. That's
Matthew 24.
Are you with me there? Yes. So, how are
you going to tell me Israel, the Jews,
are God's chosen people when Jesus gave
the sign that when the temple and
Jerusalem will be destroyed, 70 AD,
that's the sign I'm done with them and
now my kingdom, my people, my
>> [cough and clears throat]
>> chosen,
the church on Earth that's now all over
the world that is made up of Jews,
Gentiles, males, females, free and
slave. That's God's true Israel. In
fact, you know what he said about these
Jews
and Jerusalem that reject him? You know
what he called them in that chapter
you're reading?
If you open up Matthew 23, the entire
chapter, and you read from 13 all the
way to 36, he calls them brood of
vipers,
whitewashed sepulchers.
You make people twice the children of
hell hell. You don't enter the kingdom,
nor do you allow anyone else to enter
after you. And then I want to guess what
else he tells them.
He says they are sons of Cain.
They belong to Cain, their father. Do
you know that?
If you open up that chapter, Matthew 23,
open it up.
>> Um I'm going to show you something. Read
32 to 36. Matthew 23:32 to 36.
>> [clears throat]
>> "Go ahead then and complete what your
ancestors started."
>> Notice, you're going to follow the
footsteps of your ancestors. They
sinned, you're going to sin and you're
going to follow in their footsteps and
you're going to reach the limit of their
sins. Once you reach the limit, that's
when I'm going to bring destruction on
you. Right?
See what he's saying there? Go ahead and
do what? Complete
>> Complete or fill up what was begun by
what?
Your ancestors. Ah, okay.
So, go ahead.
"You snakes, you brood of vipers, Wait,
what did he call them? Brood of vipers.
>> Snakes.
Satan appeared as a serpent snake,
right? Yes. Remember Genesis 3, the
serpent that was Satan? Yes.
And here he says, "You snakes, you brood
of vipers. You are sons of snakes.
You're snakes. You're serpents." Wow,
Jesus wasn't politically correct, was
he?
Now, keep going. "And so, upon you will
come all the righteous blood that has
been shed on Earth, from the blood of
righteous Abel the blood of
Zechariah, son of Berechiah, whom you
murdered between the temple and the
altar." Okay, so the blood of all the
murders of the righteous will fall on
who?
Upon So, upon you, the
>> Upon you, Jerusalem, right? Cuz what did
37 say? "O Jerusalem, Jerusalem, Yes.
So, the blood of all the righteous
by their fathers
started by their ancestors will fall on
that generation, on Jerusalem, which is
why he's going to destroy Jerusalem and
the temple?
>> [snorts]
>> Yes. Because that's what 37 to 39 says,
right? "Jerusalem, Jerusalem, you who do
what to the prophets?" Killed the
prophets. So,
what is he talking about? Jerusalem, the
temple, will be destroyed as a
consequence of all
of all the righteous
starting with Abel, culminating in Jesus
and the Jerusalem is responsible for all
that, right?
Yes.
You see it, right?
I do. Um I'm not troubling you, but
before you get troubled, why is the
blood of Abel going to fall on their
head? Who
Cain.
Do you understand what Jesus just said
about those Jews who rejected him?
He says, "Cain is your ancestor."
Because when Cain
Cain is your spiritual father.
You belong to him, not to Abraham.
There's that teaching again.
When Jesus said, "If you don't believe
in Christ, you do not belong to Abraham.
You're not true Jews." These Jews, by
rejecting Jesus and wanting to have him
murdered, he says, "You belong to Cain."
You share in his
cuz he's your father, not Abraham.